you know Milo Ventimiglia has a big dick
he got venti in his name people really
forward online
I do have venti my name hey am i live in
familia from the film second act and we
were here with BuzzFeed to read some
first tweets I want to [ __ ] my Levin
seemly is so badly that I learned how to
spell Ventimiglia that is impressive
have Milo Ventimiglia read thirst tweets
so we can congratulate him on his big
dick energy is that dick is an [ __ ]
big big dick energy wow you know we're
just gonna let that one go I want Milo
Ventimiglia to suffocate me with his
thick ass cheeks and snap my neck
you wouldn't be around to enjoy it I'm
sorry pal Milo Ventimiglia I want to
lick your toes baby okay I want my lovin
Tamilians cute ass crooked smile on my
tombstone actually you probably do it in
like your text just do the back slash
and then the colon and there you go
you've got a model of intimately crooked
mouth just a crooked if someone told me
milo ventimiglia is incredible edible
ass what was the first goddamn thing you
see on this is us i would have watched
this show when it first came out you
don't just need my ass there's a lot of
great stuff going on this is us so
welcome to the party I want my love
Vince Millie's moustache to swallow me
it's funny he tries to swallow me all
the time that's why I got rid of it it's
crazy the things that have had a boner
for my livin Familia for over 10 years
that would I feel like inhibit a lot of
life or enhance it either way Milo
Ventimiglia couldn't light me on fire
with a faulty kitchen appliance any day
of the week actually let's not do that
let's not light anyone on fire because
that's just not cool my favorite part of
rewatching Gilmore Girls for the fifty
nine thousand three hundred and seventy
fourth time is falling in love with Milo
Ventimiglia over all over again every
single
time thank you Maddy I love you back
last one if you google milo ventimiglia
you'll get pregnant you know what that
one's going home with me today
that one's going home with me
[Music]